welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
there you go
all right let's get into it I'm so
excited there's so many things to
discuss a lot of fun going on all right
oh here we go everybody is jacked he
keeps his jeans high and tight just test
redoes that's true yes I've seen him
with jeans yes very very high very tight
mm-hmm and big arms okay
actually he's I don't know you think
he's bigger than you are with respect to
muscles - I don't know Oh is Randy don't
bring anyone love into this
[Music]
you know did you know that g1 eto why
yes I did I heard yeah now someone said
that he lip synced or something yeah he
got ripped apart by country music fans
yeah he lip synced on the CMA the
Country Music Awards whatever they and
he's such a good entertainer he doesn't
go to the year he doesn't need to do
that so you wouldn't fuckin do that
Heather Walker that's right well here's
what a song has been banned from those
owners and banned from ever he's about I
think we're gonna see ol wheeler on the
Supreme Court and argue in his case that
we've been censured Target Walmart they
won't plug they way they will play a
shit fuckin too dangerous man yeah
that's that's why got Entertainer of the
Year that is just so crazy how does a
dealer major G slap up he's still
terrible his Instagram stories and I
watch every one of them I love him I
cherish them cuz they're so shitty dude
I love by the way this shit when ya
nerds this happened over the course of
the show a bunch of times no but like
when our listeners get up a shout out on
like hey guys marty is jacked he keeps
his jeans high and tight and then they
have no idea what's going on it brought
me back to look what's on page one of my
drops page monkey Todd remember the
original he got on TMZ out there yeah
the ones they take call and I think of
the internet show yeah and he got Harvey
Levin that was the first time we ever
love Harvey Levin the first time we ever
had a mommy sabotage yeah this is page
one like yeah right when the show
started yeah he was talking about where
they do I guess that's just on Harvey
Harvey that's just the but he caught on
I remember he was like all right you
know where the dudes are at heart
okay this is great cuz this is like a
local radio a local news show like a
local affiliate I guess they sing
Rochester New York
yes and so it's like two square for
those of you who aren't watching on
YouTube like to total you know probably
they're like sneeze yeah like they're
funny but they're you know they're sweet
they're nice guys yeah I mean they're
kind of boners but they're like nice
funny guys you know yeah bamboozled by a
mommy what happens man play with mom you
never know what's going to happen you
know having me laugh I like that stuff a
lot I fucking love that stuff yeah yeah
it's like it kind of is um you know it's
to me it reminds me of the hey mommy
thanks Jane stuff yeah I almost forgot
about how much fun that was you should
if you listen to the show now I can't
you know give it that much context all
at this moment but you look up I think
there's are some on YouTube
if you look up hey mommy thanks jeans
and with relation to your mom's house
it's where we got people to go to
drive-throughs and basically refer like
yous jokes from the show in their
drive-thru orders is amazing I mean well
and it's something that in private life
you and I still practice all the time we
yesterday decided to actually have fun
for the first time in a long time and we
took off the rest of the afternoon and
we went to eat Italian food yeah and
then we went to a movie and everybody we
call mommy or jeans mommy or jeans mom
you're just and nobody still to this day
and even like the guy shaved parmesan
onto my plate and I go wow
good job jeans nobody has been saying
good job to somebody is like especially
if you act impressed like good job jeans
as shaving parmesan I think he just
thought like this guy's a fucking idiot
you're drunk
yeah yeah good job get shot really
impressed when you poured that water
change good job
and then we saw the most boring movie on
the fucking plan yeah you know I kind of
regret
switching it we were gonna go see Thor
which was like everyone's raving about
but I was like I want to see that shit I
said care well you're not a comic book
not lazy
growing up so yeah yeah there's we had
different work for them too
but yeah so I went I saw a murder in a
title I was like let's go see that I
knew that would make your bring joy to
your heart to do so we saw Murder on the
Orient Express which is based on the
Agatha Christie book from 1902 and felt
like they filmed I mean it's a little
dull because it's once it's one backdrop
and Johnny Depp's in it and he's a kind
of drug you know and then it there also
was the I don't know you know in in a
thriller where there's you need
suspicion you do need to like lead
people and then misdirect and yeah but
when you do it like 10 11 times it also
starts doing yeah I guess well that and
when you don't clue the audience in on
how the detective is coming to his
conclusions well he'll be like they
won't even show anything he'd be like I
noticed a scrape in the painting and
you're like what painting we never saw
that so he just deduces shit when yeah
that's like superhero style yeah yeah I
noticed that you farted when you walk in
the room yeah that means you must had
breakfast that's impressive
yeah well one thing that really bothered
us on in this film Dame Judi Dench isn't
it and she's great she's famished I
could watch her do anything
and she has two little lap dogs two of
us should one I thought it was two and
the whole time I mean I was concerned
because I'm like where are these dogs
shitting and pissing yeah on the train
they never show them going right never
talked about it it's kind of like that
Martian movie right with Matt Damon
where they're like where'd you jerk off
when are you not watching porn when you
ask first what bothered me about this
film much like the Matt Damon film why
aren't you answering the important
questions like yes we know who done it
but where are these malteses taking
shit's in there pisses ya cuz you're on
this train for days it's what the next
movie will probably be about is what I'm
thinking when they do a sequel where
where do the dogs shit and piss what a
neat pitch and also like I watch people
on airplanes taking international
flights with their dogs and I think well
how are those dogs pissing and shitting
another movie could be a movie about
that or a television series you're
thinking yeah that's right I thought we
could you know I know you have some TV
meetings coming up I do take Network
ones too I thought you could pitch that
and I thought for the dogs pissing and
shitting you could call it where do I go
where do I go where do we go you go
where do I go now let me give you some
advice when you when you walk in you go
where do I go I'll be like that's what
I'm talking about it's a show about dogs
shitting and pissing in places that you
don't know where they're going and then
oh that's intriguing
yes they go and then you know I need I
need three acts and I need 22 minutes
and I can blow people's minds in the
country yeah I'm feeling I should open
with you guys are dog lovers right
that's true I feel like that's the way
to get them on board and then I could be
like but where do they go when people
are on train don't you taking cars start
with like your phone and go and you hold
it up like that and you showed me like
as a picture of my dog and they're like
oh that's adorable and be like do you
know where he's shit and piss today and
then they'll be like I'm sorry babe he
went in that backyard because he was
home but what about when you see a dog
on a plane you know like right away you
grab him in like that oh I like that one
yeah and then if they don't like that
one I was thinking I could follow it up
okay well that's not that one but what
about dog dick afternoon which was one
of the original great ideas on this show
right a pitch where you take different
breeds of dogs on a walk and you explain
to the viewing audience their habits and
behavior you know the history of the dog
and then you masturbate the two dogs and
then you see if they have different
styles of orgasm ABC they do racier
stuff
foxes this is more in line
like a fox show yeah who are you
thinking of hosting you me horse Wow
your show okay what movie Cesar Millan
you do that yeah okay yeah cute blonde
and you go like hey guys I like dogs and
then den the dog episode the dogs come
[Laughter]
so right now you have a show pitching
dog shitting and pissing and coming I
can't think of a more exciting talent
moving forward for the network's do you
think our manager would like would be
what is he gonna like that I would tell
him this I would say this I have a
couple great ideas I want to surprise
you don't tell them I'm telling the
pictures in advance at all in advance
just drop it on him in the room and I'm
sure he'll be like yeah really get on
board with it I've known him a long time
yeah he'll like it he'll like it he'll
like it a lot I really like this idea
but I am serious it was distracting me
the entire time as a dog lover I was
very upset at the idea of Dame Judi
Dench keeping this dog hostage on this
train very yeah I'm serious though how
do you think they let the dog piss and
shit on that Orient Express that's a
really good question I mean I don't know
how they did it period in that era I
feel like right now we live in an era
where they're like they'll build an area
for dogs right Airport there's like
relief area for dogs but that's just
like the 1930s or something funny's I
think yeah like I guess they just let it
piss and shit where it wanted I think
that depressing too when they're
unfolding this real bummer
yeah really fuck me in the ass man
really fuck me hard I didn't like what
is this a question for you yeah
Emmitt ophea Oh a meta phobia what is
that I'm in a meta faux I don't like
vomiting oh okay I've talked about it
before honor that's deep bro yeah I
talked about on this show actually yeah
okay good I love advice I just wanted
some advice regarding a minute what is
it I'm mad a phobia I'm a 33 year old
woman I've been suffering for over 20
years how are you able to get through
with pregnancy my biological clock is
ticking with the thought of morning
sickness terrifying thanks Amanda Amanda
I hear you because I had the same exact
fear when I
was pregnant with Ellis and I will tell
you that I never vomited with him so
first of all it's a metaphor is a phobia
of vomiting and I've had it since I was
like nine years old a long time I don't
like hearing that you know I don't like
it anyways it helped me to talk about it
with my therapist if you have a
therapist I would recommend doing that
and then and then I will tell you that I
when I was pregnant with Ellis I would
get nauseous but I would will it away
but the other thing is I remember you
told me that but then you told me later
on somebody tell you about a medicine
yes so here's what you can take you got
a full disclosure I'm not Rick
recommending you take this and you talk
to your physician
don't fucking I didn't make you take it
you have to ask yeah so there's a
medicine that can suppress the spasms in
your stomach so again like that is
something you can ask your doctor to
prescribe you if you have a severe
subscribe prescribe subscribe did I say
fucking subscribe no but you're
correcting my time thank you so much
you're right yeah I got a subscription
for it yeah
because it's actually I mean I've read
about it let's say you have food
poisoning it's not necessary for it to
come out of your stomach and it can go
out the other way which is why a doctor
would prescribe it right there you go
yeah so you can wheel it away and I I
have and maybe I'm just leave you I do
think you rolled it away because all the
time I've known you
yeah not one not one how many years once
I've known you a lot but let's say we've
been together I mean you started dating
in oh five yeah so yeah yes I had 12
years knock on wood I have not vomited
number one I got food poisoning I don't
like talking about it
puking yes I remember in the sink and I
didn't like and I remember seeing the
green parts of it and I fucking flipped
out you flipped out quietly
you know what I've learned to contain my
anxiety I get it and I'm so afraid of
when Ellis is gonna get food or stomach
problems oh yeah this has happened it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen and I'm
course I'll be alone with him you'll be
on the road well speaking of dog
and vomiting yes great thanks
speaking of document vomiting Jesus
Christ what what kind of segue what are
we gonna go into now I thought it makes
total sense how louis c.k has been no
he's one of the the Titans of art of our
industry and and you know obviously if
you were alive you've paid attention to
it probably if you follow comedy and
like comedy podcasts you're probably
well versed and already but yeah there's
this um you know there's this shakedown
going down that's probably the wrong
term but there's this chizz shakedown
the gist down that's going down in
Hollywood no it's overall I think it's
it's actually a really good thing it's
like checking some pretty horrible
behavior and behavior that's been known
by the way in our community for a long
time yeah and I'm talking about I mean
when I say checking behavior I'm talking
about across the board I think it's good
to check powerful people that are
abusing their power yeah and I think
obviously the Weinstein one is massive
and he's over he's been raping people
you crazy
and then you know I made some jokes
initially about the Spacey one yeah
because I you know not that it's
whatever it's not it's not like a good
thing he was doing but I thought he was
just kind of being you know overly
flirtatious on the set like kind of like
they said he's like rubbing guy's
shoulders that don't want I was like oh
he's just he's he's doing what some guys
do to women but two guys on the set of
house of cards and then stories came out
about him with like fourteen-year-old
boys Yanks attempting to rape one
supposedly raping another and turns out
I mean at least how it's being portrayed
is that he's a fucking Savage you know
and I think those guys will never work
again
and should never work again and some and
I think you know I think Weinstein might
go to prison I hope so and there's
active investigation he's a real
predator that was open cases on him in
LA and New York yeah so they're like
they're and they're investigating trying
to find a way to charge that guy with a
real crime yeah well you know what let's
I mean he did go to rehab for three
whole days huh
so let's not forget him and space here
at the same place do you know that
they're in the same rehab facility good
for them I can compare compare notes but
what's that shit shithead that raped a
13 year old and he went to Paris Oh
Roman Polanski yeah and he's been
continued to yeah they celebrated
business loves that guy
welcome back like what I wonder if
they're going to further you know like
he's been he's been defended by show
business people for a long time I know
so one of the more alarming things if
you don't know the Polanski store you
can read it in detail but he was
convicted in Los Angeles County of sex
with a 13 year old girl and a hot tub
that he gave champagne - I don't know
they gave her a bill he you know had an
agreement of a certain amount of time to
be served the judge either retired or
died and so like the replacement judge
was like no no you're gonna go to prison
for a while and his his defense I'm
paraphrasing this stuff but like was
something about yeah but the last last
judge said we had a deal and basically
new judge was like I don't give a fuck
about your deal yeah and so he got on a
plane to Paris and that's that he's
never come back he's tried to ask for
permission to come back and Los Angeles
District Attorney's for the last
whatever 30 years have been like nope
you have an open warrant for your arrest
if you're ever and yeah you know around
US territories or anyplace anyways all
that stuff those guys are it's horrible
with Louie you know the thing that first
of all I was just like we've heard the
stories for a long time you know
particularly yeah one it's it's let's
put it this way it's it's been in our
industry we've all known the comedians
have spoken about
alas I thought it was one of the things
I'm like hmm is hearing some of these
comics go like I didn't know well the
thing is - you hear stories like the his
peer like guys are his age right right
oh they yeah come on around you didn't
know that really I mean the thing is -
but but you know again if you're in our
shoes and you hear a story like that
about somebody you don't you weren't
there you don't know all the facts you
don't know you don't know what's true
what's not what's you know what I mean
like stories the telephone game is like
okay I don't know I don't you don't know
I know nothing I don't know I here's the
thing about my thought on it is that
what he did is not okay to do clearly
it's really not okay to do that to
people
especially if like those people are you
know like in a position working for
something like if they're working under
you and like you're the boss basically
in the room right that's the whole thing
is that he was in there there you know
he's in the position of power yeah I'm
taking advantage of his powerful
position it's fucked up it is it is
fucked up yeah but again like is it is
it worth ruining someone's entire life
you're like dude I have a lot I know I
don't know how this I mean if it comes
across really callous but like when that
story broke and when the consequences
started you know coming to be I felt
like a lot of empathy for that guy not
because I thought it was okay what he
did but like I just started thinking
about somebody with you know he's got
two kids like two daughters and like and
I know that the answer to that is like
well maybe you shouldn't have fucking
done that then yeah I get it and I'm not
I'm not defending it or minimizing or
diminishing what he did but it is you
know I can't help but like I feel like
that is a fucking devastating price to
pay you know it is and I think to write
like all crimes there's different levels
of crime you have first-degree murder
second-degree murder manslaughter
manslaughter assault aggravation yeah
I think right now like to lump him in
with a Harvey Weinstein not okay to do
that it's not the same crime now is it a
crime absolutely is it is it horrible
and traumatic to have to go through
something like that with a dude yeah of
course and honestly how many of the
woman have I seen dudes doing that in
public
yeah every since I was 12 and awake and
husband dudes doing that I've never said
this publicly yeah I have my own
experience right with a person who I
worked for very early on in my show
business career or living in Los Angeles
and it was for working for somebody in a
position of power who did something in a
very inappropriate and I've told you
about I don't want to get into diesel
yeah I don't want to out the person
either because I don't know what the the
end game that I'm looking for right you
know it's just like it's kind of one of
those things where I just chalked it up
to being like that person's fucked up
and they have their own demons and you
know I don't know what's gonna happen to
them but yeah it's been a long time it's
been a long time right yeah I just died
oh man it's so fucked up I think what
really breaks your heart and it breaks
our hearts I think you and I pacifically
yeah is that Louie is such a super
talent too and you go like retard man
that's the guy we all we all look up to
as the gold standard it's one of those
things that people always you know bring
up up with these super talents that have
these flaws or these you know like like
you're Polanski is obviously a great
director right you know Michael Jackson
was one obviously like the whole world
yeah celebrated his talent and then
there was like is he fucking kids all
the time Mark Kelly are Kelly's yeah for
sure you know he's a real talk man he
really it's it's confusing and I think
it'd be Cosby was the worst cuz you're
at the same as a fan like let's take it
back
as a fan of these people it's it's such
a psychological mind fuck you're like
wait am I allowed to like this person
anymore I think the other part of it
affects people like us with regard to
Louie is that where we work in his field
yeah like you know Cosby seems so
separated from us because he's like 50
years older right and like the way he
came up but like we have like a certain
bond with Louie because Louie's kind of
like the talent-wise and like a kind of
The Cosby of our era right like he's the
class ahead of us he's the class ahead
of us but we've seen him like we
remember him having his first special
yeah and seeing the trajectory seeing
the build and so in a way he's like he's
like the big brother even of comedians
who aren't friends with him like you go
like wow like look at him doing this and
this and this you know so it's like you
kind of want to we've all kind of been
like in all even if he's not you're like
I know some people are like you know
content-wise
they're not like into him or whatever
look man objectively skill-wise he's
such a skilled comedian yes it's wild
yeah it's a fucking bummer dude there's
the whole thing I mean sad I feel like
that it happened like it that sad that
he did that and and sad for the women
that explores but I'm also sad at the
like someone's you know life being just
totally ruined totally devastated right
now yeah fine and they tried you know
and lumping in the people close to him
making it about like his manager that's
all about that stuff to your lake well
look the manager is only going by what
he's been told yeah by the client and
it's the manager's job to protect the
client so you can't you can't be like
hey the manager should have known
there's a lot of thing they're not
omnipotent yeah like you know what a
mislead the person that you're wanting
to help you cover for it so he's gonna
be like I didn't really you know of
course he's gonna minimize
most likely and if you have a good
manager they're gonna fucking try to
help you yeah they're gonna help you out
of the mud so and he wasn't away he
wasn't helping a superstar
that's right at the time people are like
yeah of course you're gonna protect this
was fuckin a long time ago so I mean I'm
not like I know people are already gonna
jump on us for the way that we're
phrasing this I guess but I just feel
like part of what's going on right now
is there's like a stereo which again the
end result is that it's gonna it's gonna
check people in power to really think
twice before they yes and this is a good
thing and this is a necessary move in
the evolution of equality for women this
is a necessary okay but it is a
necessary thing to do to start weeding
out these jerk-offs that are abusing
women abusing and molesting children by
the way Cory Feldman's coming out and
naming people and who in the 80s were
molesting and he said this is a known
thing that they're opposed to that came
out against Spacey he had 14 yeah I mean
there's a fourteen-year-old boy and
that's fuckin unbelievable but it's it
is it is a necessary thing to get things
more equal and to clean up the business
a little bit you know yeah
it's it's terrible the whole thing is
devastating it's terrible man about the
truth right yeah all right that's enough
show business are you know we usually
don't talk current events but you know
this is happening in our in our
community so yeah maybe yeah have to I
could maybe mix it up and or change the
speed a little bit by telling you that
we finally got some more she's retarded
mentally from our listeners
oh thank thank God I mean she's retarded
and machines will then have become the
to smash hit songs of the fall season
it's really really taken over and you
know there were some she's retarded that
came in last week we played and some are
okay
somewhere better but there's some
definitely better ones in this week I'll
give you a couple here he's a the club
mix
[Music]
like oh I love it
absolutely fantastic
you actually could play that at any Co
you could yeah it would be great if we
could have that played at a club and
then people halfway through be like wait
a minute
what are they what are they singing this
is song sheets this is Tim from
Australia ready
[Music]
it's not exactly great very good work
[Applause]
and then the one that's great that's Tim
from Australia thanks Tim thanks Tim the
one I've been waiting for I told you I
met him finally a few weeks ago when I
was in Austin gaping dad Wow he's sent
in some of the great hits of your mom's
house music history a celebrity in our
on our show oh yeah he's an OG and he
made a she's retarded so you know I feel
like some of our producers our music
producers on this show are have earned
it you know that he deserves it I
haven't even heard it and I just feel
like he deserves it already he always
does a good job such quality work always
so here we go ready finally the world
premiere of she's retarded from gaping
dad
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I made a fire no fucking song
this is an epic masterpiece it really is
it incorporates so many of our favorites
it really is I'd say what I'll do is
this song is I just a full-length song I
will close this episode with that full
song mega bridge and get over a present
over it
so like those two I know do you know who
scrim is by any chance you always say
what what are you gonna lick my scrim no
I say scrum no this is a wrapper
his name is scrim he also goes by
suicide Christ okay and he's in the
suicide boys oh boy that's not a bad
name there's the Dead Boys sua same way
it's not a bad name for a band
well I want you to pay attention okay -
what scream is saying here because I
feel like you could learn a thing or two
okay I did it before
it's pretty fucking nice like I enjoy
yeah right mm-hmm okay
I like having like oh like a blackness
with a fat ass spread and cheeks like
put it on my face you know I'm saying
why here's the stipulations if I'm gonna
do some shit like that you can go okay
yeah pink eye yeah you got he's got some
stipulations though depilation got some
stipulations man okay you know sure some
shit like that big oh thank god what are
the stipulations women first off no you
fart in front of me ever period I think
it sit down yeah party's over like I'm
breaking up - right in there Wow oh no I
could not have a relationship with scrim
you couldn't yell you're also not black
he said like a Oh hitch with a black
bitch sorry right I meant that I did
hear that I'm sorry I didn't yeah I was
hoping he'd be an equal-opportunity
but like he likes white bitches you
better never fart so yeah you're out of
them I'm married yeah the running yeah
for scream yeah one of two things has to
happen
both things happen and it just makes it
better for me what's that no I gotta
bleach to hate us oh stop are you saying
there's gotta be fresh gotta be clean
and I don't know what else can get it
more cleaner than bleach and a
motherfucker I mean correct me if I'm
wrong
that's a mad side with the fucking bed
it's a carcinogen cleaner her fucking
asshole man mass and shit like y'all
told him I was wrong to be so off of him
okay but why but wait a minute now he
likes black women but he's asking them
to bleach their anuses which is actually
skin bleaching right of you bleach your
skin around your anus which is I imagine
very painful I'm sure and if he likes
the darker ladies why are you asking him
to bleach it lighter it seems
counterintuitive yes why don't you ask
for a darker right why don't you paint
your asshole black yeah you know that's
what I would say
can you paint your asshole black he does
have those knuckle tattoos that I like
so got a lot of tattoos I do like those
he talks the way yeah secondly if she
gets like fresh like straight out the
shower
well that's like no I'm saying like so
it's still sitting eyes open so like oh
yeah then I'm throwing her down and
yeah so he requires ass bleaching or
suds in the hole I think it's much
easier to wash your asshole than to get
it but he's saying suds still in there
like sofas he's just saying like you're
extra clean yeah then he doesn't really
like eating ass I feel like he likes
though you're saying that he should have
liked it a little dirt a little tank Wow
well if you're into eating buttholes
don't you want it to be kind of in a
state of a butthole he's then he's when
he may as well lick a a forearm or a
forehead you know I'm saying what you're
saying like it then the taboo is gone if
there's no tag on it yeah little stink a
little bit right but not a lot right a
lot it's too tangy
like a whole day of me Oh God running
around would you like my butthole after
Pilates no no no that's like he doesn't
really like licking ass is what I'm
trying to say he's got all these rules
and stipulations he's got high standards
this guy scrim yeah I don't think he
really likes it I don't know if he
doesn't really like it but he's got some
you know he's like you better never fart
in front of me
but I never see a fucking hair I can't
deal gotta be bleached they're gonna be
soap yeah his standards are just too
high for much like I mean I can't get my
be whole hairless I don't wax wait why
can't you get a hairless I don't wax
down there I don't believe in pouring
hot wax on my most sensitive parts of my
body and then get it
I won't I refuse I think it's cruel and
unusual punishment I think it's it's I
just won't do it why for what when I can
use a razor
let's see but you still use a razor yeah
I'm the undercarriage and I can get my
be whole I can kind of graze my asshole
to get I'm not very I mean you know me
I'm not you know my hair I'm not very
hairy no I don't think compared to you
know yeah so it's not a big issue for me
I've been with bitches that got hair
coming out everywhere I got I was with a
girl
once I thought she had a pair of balls
in her panties like I was like what is
in there talking about so hairy oh hey
Henry that the underwear having like a
bald you know oh I swear to you she was
so hairy that she had a bulge and I was
like nah and then when the when the
panties dropped it was just like I mean
it was what year was this 70-64 I know
it felt like it was I mean it was but
she was just super hairy you know now
but that what I'm serious what year is
this what year is a nice um yeah yeah
like yeah maybe 2000 yeah yeah so you'd
think like you've gotten the memo that
general societal consensus is shave or
wow you know trim it down yeah I mean
she was shaved where she needed to be
shaved but oh you're saying like so
strong right there's so much bulk right
I know I mean she was just a hairy hairy
product now you do the courtesy of
trimming up down there I try to yeah I
trim it pretty I mean sometimes I'll
forget and I'll look I'm cool now god I
can see where my dog that it doesn't
bother me / I don't care but do you know
that the trend now for girls is totally
bald
wait that's been four years I feel I
just heard about it on the Internet no I
swear to God I I was reading something
and apparently bald is where the party's
at and weight hasn't bald been the thing
with less than 15 years yeah but when I
was a single girl when you and I started
dating the landing strip was friend the
norm so now I'm saying that the the
Hitler is is gone now it's just totally
baby beaver
I feel like baby beavers been around for
a while and I I tell you I had a few
baby beeves I'm not that like it doesn't
it being hairless doesn't really do
anything for me I prefer the landing
strip I feel as an adult as a mature
baby that's what it is like I have few
big hairs I'm a grown man yeah I had
puberty beard it is kind of weird
Zelda shades it like a little kid yeah
yeah it's weird yeah I I mean look I'm
not one of these people that grows out
my armpit hair I do let the leg hair go
cuz it's blonde
I think hairless cocks are weird you
know oh that's so weird or when a dude
shaved like che
a perfect patch over it like when it's
really well you see that in corn yeah
it's like he shaves like how I would
shave a like a beard line like the
Puerto Rican they shoulda leakin beard
yeah yeah there's no weird over a dong
like it feels like it should be yeah
trim it down but I think that's for
porno like the shaping so they look
bigger on camera isn't no but yeah but
I'm saying like some of them are so
meticulously shaving I'm like it's gay
it's a little homosexual yeah it's a
little much
yeah yeah maybe that's what it is
this feels feminine to be like I put the
line here and then I use the ruler and
then I mean it was the same here it's
like yeah I'll just trim that down make
it look like come on sweetheart
why don't you put a bow on it you know
what I don't like is uh personally like
buff guys yeah let's shave their chest
and then you see the growth come in a
little yeah personally I just I'm like
just have hair some people are really
into here look I'm look at my head you
are I know like a fucking space monkey
you get ready to shout out in his face
yes like a fight crap I have to fart
when we gonna get these fart mics yeah
it's been a while that was not um I did
I went for it you know what it is I've
been getting my hair cut by the same guy
you've been getting your hair cut by I
love that guy everybody and her family
goes to now oh it's great and we've done
different things but then over the years
this front area has thinned out and so I
believe in like when you're thinning in
an area keep it short
yeah so I've been keeping it short but
then the more that it thins out it's
like I get a haircut and then a week
later I'm like oh now it's just like
glaringly fin oh that's why you're doing
it because you feel like the grow-out is
making it show more it does I don't feel
like it does it does so it's like to me
it's like just throw in the towel and go
I'll just go shorter so they did the
haircut last longer oh I see I didn't
know your reasoning I didn't know I
didn't understand this logic I really
really know I thought you were you just
wanted to be like you know cool guy like
an older dad and just go ahead and get
your dad your dad cut you know no I just
feel like I'm getting haircuts that last
ten days oh yeah I did not know this
yeah I think it looks great I think
you're very handsome
we're very like what's going on I don't
like change different I was like oh shit
I don't like change
I've been with the same hairdresser
since I was 20 years old that's 21 years
I've been going to Alan no one else has
colored my hair yeah since that's only
Alan I don't like change and I like you
to look the way yeah I'm a I'm used to
you looking you know it doesn't look
that different it took me a while to get
used to it at first I was shocked
because I'm like wow yeah that's like
that's a real dad you're like Jesus
Jason Statham my new husband but now I
like it because I feel like it's more
rugged I feel like you're like oh you
know you need go hunt you also has the
same hair cuz me that's right I knew I
liked him for some reason you say okay
so I want to bring up something we
didn't talk about when we were on
vacation with your family in August okay
it was your father's 70th birthday oh my
god yeah and either we know we didn't
this I don't think we reported they like
we did we must have mentioned this well
we're gonna do it again yes I think it's
hilarious I think it's a good idea and
it was a 70th birthday and both your
sisters and their spouses and your
mother all of us were there and well why
don't you tell the story because this is
your brilliant idea um was I did I first
mentioned it or I first write it down
for like a card I forget so I think I
mentioned it I think we were at I think
because we had dinners the night before
in the night of right of his birthday
and so is all of us together and I said
oh like mom dad turns 70 tomorrow
are you gonna give him a are you gonna
16 item tonight and she goes what like
69 for 70 and I go no are you gonna are
you gonna give in a 69 the night this is
last night being 69 and of course
there's like giggling at the table and
my dad's like Tommy and then everyone
starts laughing and she's like what what
and she's like that's what an innocent
mother is yeah really doesn't know she's
no idea what 69 is and so like then
Maria's like ah it's something mm I was
like six would and she's like yeah and
she's like what they're trying to be you
know polite about it it's just she's
like please tell me and she's like okay
you know like guy puts his mouth down on
you and then you go down on him like
what so they're like trying to like
paint the picture yeah your mom's head
is exploding like yeah she can't put it
they can't even fathom what's happening
and then I you know once you find
figured yeah she was like oh and just
you know roll her eyes was like that
just sounds horrific yeah to her it's
like you might as well be like can-can
dad shit in your mouth so right but then
I later on I go hey you know what you
should do when we get together tomorrow
you should be like I'm gonna go 69
you're your dad and she was she was down
with it
we had we had dinner and she was like
I'm gonna give 69 nine so fun but I
think by the way what would be really
fun for our listener if any of you this
is how I propose you do it get a camera
going or at least an audio recording but
you can maybe better and ask your mom
regardless of her age let's say your mom
is 47 be like hey when Dad when dad's
about to turn 70 do you think you guys
will 69 no the night before his 70th
birthday on the last night of him being
69 will you give him 60 yeah will you
guys be 69
will you guys 69 and just see if they
laugh or they get upset and like if
they're over 70 just go like hey when
dad turned 70 did you 69 them I guess a
happy birthday ever been 69 for last
night yeah
or if your dad's dead be like if dad was
still here do you think you'd 69 them
and his birthday so stupid it's so
stupid
because we were talking about it like
remember when you were like you first
heard about what 69 was yeah and you
were like 12 or 13 or whatever and
you're like well we're gonna do that all
the time oh yeah I'm married with 69 I
just thought that would be the
mountaintop like them one day it'll be
the best fucking thing ever and I
remember doing it well because you're
doing the work and trying to receive the
pleasure yeah it's good it's
counterproductive I know cuz you want to
be like okay it's like eating and
shitting at the same time like you got
to do one or the other you can't do both
I mean you can you can't be you're not
gonna enjoy own for it you know yeah but
you're not gonna enjoy either one fully
true cuz you're working you're doing
work so image effort there's a Jewish
prayer for shitting no from blue Ben I
thought this was bullshit because I've
never heard of it I grew up super Jewish
but it's totally legit hey shit lers was
glass and last episode you came across
your discussion of the sacred releasing
yeah that was that guy that was talking
about really being present for your
shitting and the need for prayer was
squeezing out your chocolate dough let
me save you the work us Jews beat you to
it here's the English translation of the
prayer usually referred to as the
bathroom blessing Oh blessed are You
Lord our God King of the universe who
fashioned man with wisdom and created
within him many openings and many
cavities
it is obvious and known before your
throne of glory that if even one of the
cavities is ruptured or blocked it would
be impossible to survive and to stand
before you even for a short period of
time blessed are You God who heals all
flesh and acts wondrously mm-hmm the
prayer is said while washing your hands
post brown or yellow rather than during
the act of elimination as Bunn suggested
Tina let me preemptively satiate your
curiosity if you have diarrhea the
blessing is recited after each instance
of said diarrhea F all the haters genes
within Jillian aka hungry tits Oh
that's I like jeans with an amazing that
is interesting
well hey this might be a good time to
bring up my appearance on the Adam
Carolla oh my god this is a real shit
centric episode today sure is it's what
we do best
yeah so I did Carolla Show you're
promoting mother inferior with yes which
if you have not yet seen Kristina's
Netflix special mother inferior is where
is it mother inferior where can it be
see on Netflix net flix you can see it
all over any of the many hundred
thousand countries that now have Netflix
and it's streaming and it's it's really
great and it's really well received
you've been promoting it everywhere and
I was nice to meet Adam Carolla I've
been listening to him since forever I
grew up here in LA and back when he was
on k-rock doing love line and he's also
you know one of these podcasts Giants
madmen shucker not crazy yeah he's
amazing very very gracious very kind
very fun so it just spontaneously
happened we were doing some topics and I
happened to get into this I thought you
guys might enjoy it yeah Adam do you
have a bidet situation or are you just
mashing that poo in here for just
rubbing it my my thing is is I with the
shower so you know shit the shower
shit the shower yeah I've done that but
you do a wipe before you go shower right
you don't I surprised myself you know I
keep it fresh depends on certain factors
first of all I mean I cannot believe
shown a brother out there well as
disgusting as you are you have so much
in common
Corollas a grandfather was Hungarian as
well he loves chicken paprikash and he
shits to share work now a lot of us are
shamed ashamed about it but Ari Shaffir
Adam Carolla airy and I we are all shit
to shower people and I thought it'd be
nice for all the other ones out there we
can we can all feel safe knowing that
famous people go shit to showers ladies
I'd like to yeah if I am staring and if
I'm literally just gonna step off the
commode and into the shower I'll save
the paper I'll give a hot water good
good hot water rinse down there
yeah good hot water right not even an
exploratory wipe see what happens I get
it I get it
been there and done that you know it's
not my first rodeo it reminds me of wife
Kate remember between Skippy peanut
butter and Jif peanut butter which do
you like Skippy and Jeff was Charl and I
call her okay and then between the shaky
Parmesan cheese the Kraft one or the
fresh shaved parmesan which do you like
okay and then what tell me what you
think of this because I've had another
Center into it
so when Christina goes to the bathroom
like goes caca no no I need I need your
major to weigh in on this so she goes
she goes caca and then she goes she gets
up from the toilet and she takes a
shower immediately without wiping even
once I swear to God I swear to God you
please tell me why why you think so they
don't even show it well she says she
says lay hands
wait wait she says it's a shower the
shower pressure cleans it for her but do
you think you think it's disgusting I
don't see the difference between doing
what she does and just going gaga in the
shower to do that I'm saying I barely
see the difference because if there
isn't but there is a difference
I do the brown in the toilet and like
Adam said and he bring he brought up a
really good point is that you know what
you're working with
he knows he's I'm 41 years old I've been
dumping my whole life I know what's
going on back there
I know I know what's happening it's it's
fine it's fine I did it today I did a
shit to shower today I try to do it
every morning okay what's wrong I'm
trying to set the nevermind trying to do
that there again problems you know yeah
problems make my dick soft okay
another interesting thing Adam said is
that he does not take he doesn't like
taking long dumps does he say this here
that's in the full clip but not home I
just fall off the turnip truck or
whatever else see ass in front of so I
so he likes to get it out of the way is
what you're saying
yeah he's expeditious he doesn't enjoy
the moment
he doesn't shop on line like I did like
I do our grocery shopping yeah I'll pop
a few blood vessels no I don't want it
to go that quickly yeah no I like it's
like the meat I'm like we have a toddler
we have to dog like it's the one moment
I have to enjoy my life really um how
about this machines within question oh
my god I love it
hi mommies I've been practicing on what
is this Cutler the killer Klowns
flow Oh am i reading this wrong maybe I
need to open it up no cut cutter and
I've come to a mental block no that's
the guy right he'd properly expresses
his disgust for haters with the lines
after
Zef all that haters then follows it up
with the line much love no hey well
which is it what's real what's fake
maybe he's denouncing haters while
rising above it himself could Qatar be
Jesus or is he just a terminators matrix
happy Halloween mommies Brian Gigi's wow
what a great question I mean he's right
it's paradoxical on the one hand if all
the haters and then he's like all love
no hate
if you're wondering by the way why this
computer is here it's smaller it doesn't
have all this stuff that I normally do I
had computer problem today and swap it
out last second just to do this episode
otherwise I'd be playing you some
machines within yeah but yeah but that
is a great question you know I I think
it comes down to him just not being very
conscious of what he's saying you don't
think he's on top of what he's saying
he's a stream of consciousness oh right
right it comes to him yeah you know my
song yeah my flows yeah yeah he's just
he's kind of in the moment singing my
song walking down the street yeah it is
right yeah if the haters know he's just
saying he's reporting the news from his
his mind yeah that's what geniuses do
guys they can't Wow oh yes machines
within became a smash hit single and
it's because of him in part that's true
that's really true his brainchild if you
will well we'll try to get more
obviously if he keeps creating content
we'll keep playing in here so maybe
maybe we'll we'll see if he does
something in the same vein later it's
hard to do two hits in a row maybe he
reminds me of a little bit Tupac yes I
see it I see a lot at - yeah one-armed
question my boyfriend and I are hardcore
black guys who love to fuck and love
podcasts we were thinking - you two -
y'all hug talk about how do I most
people wipe and we got to talking and
things with arms we had the question if
a woman has one arm and gets a manicure
does she pay full price what a great
question looking forward to your
infinite jeans wisdom machines within
eff all the haters much love rub rub rub
rub from Holly and Baron Texas that is a
fantastic question
Jesus that is great well we once had a
nanny offer us half-price Reiki on our 8
week old baby because our son was only 8
weeks old so normally $100 she could get
it to us for 50 I'm thinking the same
logic would apply with half a manicure
it makes sense half price what do you
think I think it makes sense but there's
really like I don't know there's only
one way to really find out I think we
should call a salon yeah tell them my
wife only has one arm and how much would
you charge her yeah that's what I'm
gonna do okay because that makes it's a
it's actually a really excellent
question sure and it's one we can find
the answer to yeah it's a machine he
says 16 yeah Jeremy okay go ahead and
got terminator yeah this one calls with
it
this one's called nailed it nailed it I
know are they I passed by it's so dumb
machines with it that's right away here
I've got one here Helen there's another
one here I get again Karen get terminate
again if all the haters haters here we
go I mean these people want my business
or what no
hi how are you good
what are you charge for a manicure my
wife I'm trying to surprise her she
wants a manicure but she has one arm
does she have to pay full price okay for
her one arm okay and she has one foot so
can she pay half of the pedicure price -
[Music]
okay okay is that that's less than
normal though right yeah that's what I'm
saying that's the discounted rate yeah
cuz she's got you know she's got one
foot and she's got one arm okay that
sounds like a great deal I'm gonna send
her there thank you right all right
Oh fair enough that's very fair yeah
very reasonable establishment yeah so
glad I've never had that before that's
kind of surprising to me yeah you think
that there would be more people with
appendages missing that I'm sure they
wouldn't I saw a woman with severe
arthritis getting her nails done their
fingers were all yeah it was really hard
do you still want to have nice you still
want it and she had like nice rings and
stuff so yeah you still want to jazz
yourself up of course wait that was a
really good question yeah another good
question that came up about dick tattoos
thought provoker Oh interesting on
episode 421 you talked about weird
places for tattoos and mentioned the
poisoned penis tattoo I immediately
thought about how that tattoo session
went I imagined the penis would be have
to be hard but wouldn't the pain of the
needle hurt so bad you'd lose your boner
mm-hmm if you did lose your boner you
think the artist made the client go to
the bathroom the rub rub rub or did he
close his eyes while the client rubbed
it to get hard again how many - well you
know I wonder if anybody this is a she
says you guys are doing good Kelly from
Missouri it's a great question Kelly and
if there's any tattoo artists that have
ever done a penis
tattoo that could enlighten us on how
that goes and whether or not you have to
be erect and if you lose your erection
cuz I imagine that that does apply there
you know it's for sure I would imagine
flaccid and then they would stretch the
skin and do it flaccid because how could
you maintain an erection that's a good
but I don't know anything about I know a
lot about dicks I'd imagine they like
stretch the skin of the penis and then
really get in there get a nice way
you're drawing stretch those nooks and
crannies yeah get the ink in yeah that's
a good point
right yeah I don't think it should be i
but I'm not a tattoo artist did you know
by the way did you know that when I
played this in the earlier in the show
dick I'll make you snap somebody in the
face did you know that that's one of the
first drops we played and then this is
actually the same lady won't do me I
don't know women hit is so I'm sure but
if they gave me in a saying
then I'm sure the women probably are
noticing this too they just saying
telling y'all their man this boy told me
to tell y'all y'all need to watch on the
y'all damn nuts and all around y'all
damn nuts
yeah right you know put this beforehand
to tell y'all if you even if you do not
get penetrated I have anal sex then you
still have an obligation to live your
nut sack up and go all round the back
that you doesn't do it they said it'd be
sneaking yeah isn't that like intuitive
for everyone I mean it's not because
she's having to do a PSA about me she's
saying like even if you don't engage in
anal sex to wash your nuts exactly I'm
not sure what that has to do with anal
but I don't know I think she's she's
misinformed yeah yeah you got the
foreskin around yeah I think they say
y'all will be pulling that dick bag to
get off but they do hope it all that
cross and
but I'm round underneath your dicks cake
they bet anyone said this shit got to
stop you say y'all need to watch okay
watch you nuts
yep cool your skin background your dick
get all that hot cake the crust and this
is when y'all shit and wipe y'all head
with that talkative she said be pieces
of small particles of shit and pieces of
tension sheet cake round y'all asshole
Oh cut that hair on your legs and don't
just depend on that toilet tissue to do
the trick
Wow there's a lot of information this
it's very very important I feel like
everything that she's saying is quite
quite obvious right yeah it's true it's
like ladies and gentlemen wear deodorant
change your underwear every day come on
we rush your teeth twice a day a lot
like dude we get it who's not doing the
basics yeah maybe she's just pushing
back maybe this is push back against all
the fucking people that have four years
now say Oh pussy stink why should push
your pussies right she's heard that her
whole life she's like fuck you wash your
dick in it which I get
I understand yeah because there's true
there is this thing about women's
vaginas just being smelly 24/7 it's like
it really it shouldn't be unless
something is going on infections or such
yeah but yeah well I'm fucking sick of
hearing how stinky vaginas are they're
not that's thank you I mean there are
stinky boxes out there I'm sure but you
know what do you expect I mean come on
it's a portal of life you guys yeah
can't be perfect come on please here we
go that boy said y'all a state and y'all
need to get this together for y'all
bring y'all dick and nuts to go over
there and go up in his butt and go to
his house we'll be back with more asked
Alexis like I didn't know it was like
this nigga ass dang it oh damn
chain and y'all taught my women stapler
three go
what is boys say yo ass is motherfucking
few there you go you're right that
you're right tom
yeah you called that one I tell you I
know dicks I know balls I know things
that smell I know it it's my it's really
my wheelhouse man yeah it's really
really do we have a dental update yeah
babe I mean why would you why don't you
do it while I let the dogs in the
kitchen it's their dinnertime hold on
yeah before I give you our listener
dental update you've been saying and
actually know what this first came up
with you know obviously my friend fat
all right Bert yeah whoo
can you imagine you've seen his mouth
right oh it's it's a garbage dump yeah
it's just it's horrific and he he
breathe huh no his teeth look like
Thanksgiving corn yeah the decoration
yeah different colors yeah it's pretty
bad and he he breathes really loud yeah
we were talking about like hey do you
think you probably like I know he snores
I we should call his wife and do it yeah
what's that snoring like sure he doesn't
wear a mouth guard at all and I've been
wearing one for years which has helped
tremendously you noticed you noted that
lately my snoring has gotten louder
I think it's cuz I haven't switched my
bands out in a while so I can switch
them out tonight I think you should
because the last two nights I've had to
poke you and then you flip over now and
I also think it might be time for a new
mouth guard babe because we've been
using the same one every night for how
many years
it's a few years now yeah yeah it's time
it's time for a new one go to the doctor
the dentist and go get a fresh one okay
or get get backups - maybe - it's a good
idea I'm surprised you haven't I don't
want to jinx it but you haven't lost
this one I've been I've had panic
attacks about losing it so I probably
should get a backup yeah I'll make this
the backup get a fresh one get a freshie
you deserve it Thanks I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it I really love it and
actually there are times now is that get
into a hotel and I'm like oh I'm so
tired
I got to take a nap yeah I just won't
even open my bag I don't sleep as well
like I mentally yeah it's not as
comfortable now
are used to that I'm used to it being
there it's like wearing your retainer
your headgear this isn't a plug for you
no I'm not saying I'm not telling you
about one I'm just saying that like if
you do snore and you want to have a more
comfortable fuller night of sleep this
is what has helped me and it helps the
person that sleeps next to me but it's a
professionally done yeah it's the whole
thing the whole thing their variants all
right we'll take them in a moment
I'll take them in a moment we're almost
done okay we are so here are yeah
anyways I'm gonna get it done
yeah it's time you deserve a fresh one
I'm brushing what I floss thanks light
I've been slacking on the flossing I
will say that your teeth and your
special look much whiter and I think
people are really going to be dazzled by
how thin you look and how white your
teeth look well I definitely looked at
if you look side-by-side the last one
yeah it's definitely different it's
really it's I think people are gonna be
really dazzled by how great you look in
this new special especially well I think
if they did if they've never seen me
before they'll be like who's that fat
guy but if you know me from before
you'll be like oh it looks better it
looks way better yeah yeah here's
another email we got we get dental
updates all the time as a reminder to
anybody to listen to the show if you
ever want to send in the song if you
ever want to send in a link if you ever
want us to watch a video if you're going
to give us a dental update the email is
always don't do Facebook don't direct
message don't always hit us up at the
gmail address that's the official email
address we have thousands of emails and
they've all come in through there that's
where we check them it's your mom's
podcast at gmail.com we there's no house
in the address your mom's podcast at
gmail.com here's the email hey mommy's
my name is Brandon and I have a dental
update for you I've been listening the
show for a few years now and I used to
fast forward past the dental updates
because I was so ashamed of my teeth 27
years old and my teeth were starting to
look like I've been eating rocks on my
life I didn't have dental insurance so I
didn't go to the dentist for over ten
years
the early onset dad mouth was real and
my genes were pretty low in loose
it got so bad that I wouldn't smile with
my teeth and it was affecting my
self-esteem and happiness after I got a
new job with good insurance my Triple D
slut wife was a great set of chompers on
her convinced me to go to the dentist to
see what we could do to get the ball
rolling on fixing my teeth
that along with years of dental shaming
from the Maine mommy's good good finally
made my appointment with we start with a
cleaning and I looked like a bloody mess
after cleaning that lasted about an hour
the dentist then did an evaluation I had
16 fucking cavities the good news is
over the course of two months I got all
16 fillings I am now finally cavity free
no longer ashamed to smile I didn't know
how good the white fillings would look I
just wanted to thank you Tom and
Christina for shaming me for years and
being a contributing factor to force me
to go to the dentist and making my smile
something not to be ashamed of you've
had a positive influence on my life and
I'm glad my wife and I have found your
show on top of the teeth you helped me
and my wife be our grossest selves ever
making farts acceptable around each
other which has undoubtedly gotten us
closer as a couple anyway sorry for the
long email but I just wanted to say
sincerely thanks jeans Brandon from
North Carolina how about that that is so
true you know when I got my veneers done
the gentleman who did them said that
people have to relearn how to smile when
they get their teeth fixed yeah because
the the muscles that actually go wonky
because you're covering underneath when
you smile or you don't smile at all I
have like that yeah I don't want to out
them but I have a good no but it's
definitely not smiling yeah I mean we
don't smile that often but it's not good
I'm saying to restrict yourself from
smiling that's though right could you
magically its faring that devastating
I've got it be devastating this is a I'm
always a fan of a coach that goes over
the top this is a youth cock youth
hockey coach littleton hockey
association removed its this this coach
from the team this is youth a youth
coach has come to our attention to
evolve a video involving one of our
coaches
and and then one of their assistants has
been circulating through social media
this says that they basically found this
to be completely unacceptable I find it
to be completely hilarious and this is
the coach in locker room given the
pregame speech to the kids I'm this kid
right here yeah yeah
ear to ear smile like this is the best
like loving my coach talking like this I
don't see what's wrong with it honestly
and he's fired up am I am I wrong I know
I'm wrong he also knows that the kids
aren't threatened because they're like
this it's funny
that's the best he said fuck the other
team fuck their coaches fuck their wives
yeah and all these kids go they can hear
us that's the best yeah they can hear
that's so that's great yeah I think
that's fine you know he that coach said
something there he goes they're gonna
we're gonna beat them so bad they're
gonna wish something the best version of
that I ever heard was a football player
one time said in an interview he said I
want to hit people so hard that they
don't want to play football anymore
that's a really good idea I was like
holy shit like that but can I tell you
something in order to win in life and in
order to succeed you do kind of have to
have that killer mentality I played in
the NFL yeah but I'll be thinking think
about that I like that people say things
like I want to hit guys so hard
yeah they shit their pants well I want
to hit them so hard I knocked their
helmet off this guy said I want to hit
people so hard they don't want to play
football any right like they want quit
the game I like that
that's inspirational I don't it
motivates me yeah I feel inspired name
is Ernie Sims that's who said that yeah
yeah my dad used to say fuck up fuck up
awkward on puffles cups with a shake a
Fayed I'm gonna hit your head so hard
it's gonna fall off oh wow yeah similar
I'm gonna hit you so hard your heads
gonna fall out different paths that I
was going down yeah looks like more
sports oh right but I mean I just did
rung a bell in in me yeah inspirational
that is inspiring yeah and did that ever
happen
no no that's but they threatened you
with it Hungarian threats go a long way
though yeah threats are good yeah all
right well I think that's it for today
gene it was definitely a fun by the way
I forgot about Skippy Skippy all day
fuckers don't you just show me that
shift crap Skippy all motherfucking day
and shaky cheese all day there's a
there's a bunch of songs but I have to
on the gaping dad song of course I mean
it's like a medley of all great things
yeah it's so great thank you all oh
don't forget this by the way in our
store the Christmas sweater is 100%
profit to charity we're doing the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles so
there's multiple Christmas products and
there's all obviously other you know we
have shirts I have signed vinyl I have a
mostly story signed completely normal
signed the vinyl there's albums their
shirts then we have some holiday stuff
like Santa Claus is black Santa Claus is
Asian Santa Claus is Latino and we have
a Santa Claus wears jeans hat like a
winter hat you know yeah it's great I
mean the quality on it it's like a sown
it's the pattern sewn in it's not a
bullshit thing but if you see the
Christmas sweater that says Santa Claus
wears jeans yeah that's all going to
charity that's awesome so and will you
know will will document it will show you
like however we get the toys or just
give them the the money it'll be like
well video it and put it up so you can
see it well start your holiday shopping
now you guys these are gonna go fast
yeah the jeans one will sell out really
soon yeah for sure
all right that's it thank you guys again
for listening and we'll see you next
week bye Jean my mommy's make a bridge
and get over
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]